what are the top cloud computing careers
for 2023 as many of you already know the
cloud computing industry has grown
rapidly over the past few years with
more and more businesses looking to take
advantage of the benefits of the cloud
the big players like AWS Azure and gcp
have announced some of their plans for
2023 and despite the Slowdown of hiring
in the recent months there are still
roles that continue to be in demand for
each of these I'll be explaining what
the role is what are the skills required
and the average salary you can expect as
someone working in this role let's get
into it so the first Cloud role I'd
recommend is a Solutions architect I'm
obviously very biased when I say that
it's the best job out there because I
was previously an AWS Solutions
architect but let me explain a Solutions
architect at AWS is pretty much a
technical advisor for customers as they
go along their Journey with using the
cloud let's say I'm an AWS Solutions
architect assigned to work with small to
medium businesses my main responsibility
would be to help these businesses design
Solutions on AWS that follow best
practices this means making sure the
solutions are scalable secure flexible
and cost effective after understanding
those requirements they then provide
them with technical guidance through
presentations architectural diagrams and
demos what's great about the solutions
Arctic role is that you don't need many
years of experience before you apply
nowadays companies like AWS offer
associate Solutions Arctic positions
where they provide you with the relevant
training required to succeed in the role
for example I was part of the AWS techu
program and they provided me with six
months of training before I started in
my team the skills required to become a
Solutions architect can be split up into
Technical and non-technical skills for
the technical side you'll need to have
an understanding of the I.T fundamentals
so networking compute storage databases
and security it also helps to have an
understanding of cloud computing and
have some initial hands-on experience
with Cloud Technologies and for the soft
skills companies look for people who are
great communicators and problem solvers
they want to hire people who can work
effectively with customers and explain
technical Concepts in a way that's easy
to understand
the average salary for an associate
Solutions architect at AWS in the US
according to levels.fyi is 162 000 and
I'll leave a link down below for you to
check the salaries of other companies
and other locations by the way I want to
point out that different companies have
different naming conventions when it
comes to their jobs in the cloud for
example a Solutions architect at AWS is
referred to as a customer engineer at
Google before applying to any role
always check the job description to
understand what the role actually
involves okay so essentially Solutions
Architects provide customers with
technical advice they can propose ideas
and solutions but it's not their job to
build anything out for the customers to
use if a customer wants someone to do
the actual implementation for them they
can ask for help from a cloud architect
which brings us to the second role a
cloud architect unlike a Solutions
architect who is focused on providing
technical guidance Cloud Architects are
more focused on helping customers
implement the solution so a typical day
for a cloud architect could involve
helping custom customers improve on
their Cloud infrastructure as well as
meeting key stakeholders and decision
makers to discuss their long-term Cloud
strategy as I've mentioned earlier
different companies have different
naming so if you're interested in this
role also look out for jobs with the
title Cloud consultant and Cloud
developer the skills required to become
a cloud architect are very similar to
that of a Solutions architect because
both roles are Technical and customer
facing however Cloud Architects will
typically need to have stronger
programming skills as well as a deeper
understanding of the technical I.T
fundamentals the average salary of an
entry-level Cloud architect in the US is
around 165 000 and if you have some
relevant past experience working in Tech
the salary might be higher now you might
be thinking what if I don't come from a
technical background and have no
interest in working with cloud services
are there roles in the cloud industry
where I don't have to be technical this
brings us to rule number three a sales
development representative I'm really
excited to talk about this role because
there's not many videos out there
explaining what the role actually
involves sales development
Representatives or sdrs were short are
sales professional is responsible for
generating new business opportunities
for their company this can include
reaching out to potential customers
setting up sales meetings and qualifying
business leads for example if I were an
SDR at AWS my main responsibility would
be to identify potential customers and
get them interested in using AWS as an
SDR it's important to have strong
communication and interpersonal skills
this will help you explain the benefits
of your company's products and services
to potential customers and persuade them
to start using those products and even
though it's not a technical role an
understanding of cloud services is a
bonus the average salary for sales roles
according to levels like FYI is a
hundred and thirty eight thousand
dollars but in many companies there's a
commission-based model where the more
sales you generate the higher your total
salary will be now if you're looking to
improve both your Tactical and
non-technical skills I'd recommend
checking out today's video sponsor
skillshare skillshare is offering a one
month free well and I personally love
some of the courses I've been taking
it's an online learning community with
thousands of classes for anyone who
loves learning and wants to explore
their creativity and learn new skills if
you have specific skills you're trying
to learn skillshare is a great place to
start from ticket Finance to
productivity graphic design and more you
can find classes that will match your
goals and interests here is a Class by
hashtag learning providing an absolute
beginner's introduction to Amazon web
services and you can see here that they
have a bunch of courses to help you
improve your communication and
presentation skills the first 1000
people to use the link down below will
get a free one month trial of skillshare
so thank you skillshare for sponsoring
today's video another role where
technical skills are not required is an
account manager so while sdrs are
focused on identifying new business
opportunities account managers are
responsible for growing and maintaining
existing relationships with the
customers for example account managers
at AWS provide ongoing support and
guidance to help customers optimize
their use of AWS Cloud they may also
work with other teams to identify
different opportunities to help the
customer even further you can kind of
think of account managers as the main
point of contact for customers when
they're going about their journey of
using the cloud if customers need some
guidance when using the cloud account
managers will help bring in the
necessary people and resources similar
to an SDR account managers will also
have to have good communication and
interpersonal skills they need to be
able to communicate effectively with
customers and other stakeholders both in
person and in writing a knowledge of
cloud computing and it is preferred but
with that being said most companies
provide you with on-the-job training to
help you understand their products and
services and because most account
manager roles are commission based it's
hard to provide an exact salary range
but from my experience working at AWS
I've seen account managers getting paid
anywhere between two hundred thousand
dollars to four hundred thousand dollars
depending on their annual bonus the
fifth role I'd recommend looking into is
a cloud support engineer this is a
Hands-On technical role focused on
providing guidance to customers when
they face technical issues so anything
from helping custom troubleshoot issues
to answering questions about products
and services I have a video on my
channel where I interviewed Elisa a
cloud engineer at AWS and she does a
really good job at explaining the role
and the skills required the average
salary for a cloud engineer in the US is
around 153 000 and as always I recommend
searching on websites like Glassdoor and
levels.fy to find out what the salary
range is in your country alright so this
brings us to the end of this video
please comment below what your favorite
Cloud role is and I'll see you soon bye
for now